marque de baskets qui habille les trois
plus plus célèbres avec l'heureux avec
leur slogan qui est une sorte de voile à
deux religieuses la devise oui c'est ça
de profession de foi quasiment
exactement et des plus conséquents et ce
qui est intéressant pendant votre votre
choix justement c'est d'avoir des
marques sont le produit parce que la
marque se suffit à elle-même elle
devient la cause
à la rigueur elle pourrait pratiquement
ne rien nous vendre le but c'est quand
même nous vendre quelque chose au bout
du compte mais mais qu on communie
autour d'elle et cons et qu'on se sent
exister par elle consciente qu'elle nous
investit bon et ça devient un art that's
du principe est évidemment c'est
insatisfaisant c'est beaucoup plus
satisfaisant croire en une marque de
chaussures quand un principe politique
ou spirituelle donc on a en a on a un
procès d'un acte de substitution pour
nous encombre et sans un plein des
samares chose dit il ya quelque chose
d'un peu pathétique quand on voit ses
marques
tentez créez de la mythologie certaine
ils parviennent parfois il ya un
engouement il ya un rêve via ses ailes
sont tellement chargé de puissance mais
je parle de puissance rêvez pas de
puissance économique
parfois on a l'impression que ça marche
et d'autres fois on se dit c'est un peu
pitoyable il voudrait nous faire rêver
alors qu'ils nous vendent de la
verroterie je vais répondre oui non et
oui et ça fonctionne comme ça c'est à
dire que dans un premier temps ça marche
c'est à dire qu'on nous dit on nous dit
d'ailleurs suggestives par des campagnes
publicitaires par défaut de roue par
toutes sortes de procédés on me dit bon
ta vie vaut pas grand chose n'a pas
vraiment d'amis bon ta carrière se passe
pas comme tu le voudrais mais une bière
une marque de chaussures une moto pas
tous réglés comme en font cette moto et
tu sera la figure que tu vois cette
figure ce sera toi donc est donc sacré
harley davidson des grands meetings aux
états unis où tous les propriétaires de
deux motocyclettes de cette marque se
rencontrent des communions 1,10 mais ce
bond est évidemment que exercer mon nom
ça ne marche pas
[Musique]